im märz 2009 10 zeigte dog einer
reportage der rts kollegen über dein
baby handel in sri lanka in den jahren
zwischen 1980 und 2000
gestohlene kinder in vergangene mitte
gefälschte dokumente
zu der zeit gut der markt mit
internationalen adoptionen
kinderlose paare aus europa und der
schweiz unterstützen diesen baby handel
ohne es zu wissen
in der schweiz stecken die zuständigen
behörden den kopf in den sand
heute sind die adoptierten babys
erwachsen und suchen nach ihren
leiblichen eltern ein schwieriges
unterfangen da die meisten dokumente
gefälscht sind
auch in anderen ländern wurde gleich
gehandelt
im libanon zum beispiel wo wir auf einen
weiteren skandal gestoßen sind
[Musik]
wir treffen sarah ineichen in lorch
wieder sarah hat in der rts reportage
ihre geschichte erzählt wie sie im alter
von wenigen wochen von ihrer leiblichen
mutter getrennt und als adoptivkind in
die schweiz verkauft wurde
heute trifft sarah katrin beschossen
sie ist ebenfalls opfer des baby handels
1984 adoptiert kathrin besatzung voller
zuversicht zwei kinder aus sri lanka
sie gingen davon aus dass sie alles
richtig gemacht hatte mit einem legalen
adoptionsprozess in der schweiz erst
durch die reportage erfährt sie von den
machenschaften bei der adoptionen in sri
lanka das war eine schallende ohrfeige
ich fühlte mich betrogen ich weinte ich
war am ende
ich kam mir vor als hätte ich etwas
gestohlen
als hätte ich etwas schlechtes getan
dabei wollten wir etwas gutes tun
erzählen was damals vorsichtig
man hat uns die kinder in die arme
gelegt
bei ihr das heißt beim ist da silva sie
ist einer der ermittlerinnen die den
baby handel organisiert hat für sie
arbeitete eine anwaltskanzlei mit der
die adoptionen mit den falschen müttern
legalisierte ein sehr lukratives
geschäft
in gang draußen legten auch andere
kinder die adoptiert werden sollten
unter schlimmen bedingungen diese beiden
fotos wurden gemacht bevor wir ankamen
das hier ist meine tochter und das ist
mein sohn ganz klein und allein
er liegt in seinen exkrementen und
überall sind flehen
es war kaum auszuhalten
was denkst du wenn du heute diese bilder
an schaafs nachdem du die reportage
gesehen hast
das ist eine industrie es ist unmöglich
aber wir wussten damals nicht viel über
das ausland trainern bekannten mir da
nichts wir wussten nicht ob es überall
so ist diese armut
wir kamen nicht auf die idee dass es
nicht mit rechten dingen zugeht
katrin ist verbittert damals hat keine
schweizer behörde sie auf irgendetwas
aufmerksam gemacht ich wurde sehr wütend
auch auf die behörden weil ich erfuhr
dass sie zumindest teilweise davon
wussten
wir mussten uns als glaubwürdig
ausweisen wurden genauestens unter die
lupe genommen und sie wussten schon dass
mit den adoptionen etwas nicht stimmte
aber niemand sagte uns etwas
sarah sarg wurde 1986 in sri lanka
adoptiert sie trifft sich mit ihrem
anwalt
er ist auch ihr cousin und hilft ihr
ihre leibliche mutter und ihre wurzeln
zu finden
du musst diese unterscheidung kennen das
genaue prozedere und muss klar sagen ich
will das und das wenn du das nicht tust
erhältst du die nötigen dokumente wohl
nicht sofort sarawak ist ebenfalls durch
dorn da silva vermittelt worden
in der schweiz kommt sie zu
adoptiveltern im kanton neuenburg
am anfang läuft alles gut doch mit der
pubertät kommen die fragen zu ihrer
identität und es wäre dir schnell
bewusst dass es nicht einfach ist danach
zu suchen wenn man praktisch keine
anhaltspunkte hat
es braucht viel mut als adoptierte
hinzustehen und seinen adoptiveltern und
dem ganzen umfeld zu sagen ich will
wissen wo ich herkomme
ich dachte dass sich allein wenn in
dieser situation dass ich alleine gegen
die behörden kämpfen muss aber dann
begriff ich dass dem nicht so ist
sondern dass wir viele sind
ich hoffe ganz fest dass das hilft
[Musik]
zuerst wendet sie sich an die gemeinde
ohne erfolg dann an den kantonen
es dauert fünf jahre bis sie teilweise
antworten bekommt sie erhält ihr
adoptions dossier allerdings ist es
nicht vollständig es fehlen wichtige
teile
einiges scheint da nicht zustimmen ein
dokument welches das einverständnis zur
adoption bestätigt ist datiert bevor
sarah überhaupt zur welt kam
wie kann ein gericht eine adoption
gutheißen ohne diese unklarheit zur
sprache zu bringen
danach fragt dann gibt es niemanden bei
der verwaltung der sagt ja das ist
dieses doch sehr haben sie alles was
dazu gehört
in diesem fall hat die behörde und zwar
das dossier gegeben aber ohne uns zu
sagen dass es noch ein anderes gibt dass
irgendwann in einem archiv liegt
falscher papiere in korrekte daten
nahmen die ins leere führen das alles
lässt wenig hoffnung die biologische
familie zu finden
mit diesen dokumenten weiß ich nicht ob
ich etwas finde auch wenn ich die
hoffnung nicht aufgeben mein kampf
besteht auch darin die wahrheit
aufzudecken
vor allem was die dokumente betrifft
damit ich auf meiner suche weiter kommen
ich glaube nicht dass ich meine mutter
jemals finden werde weil alles gefälscht
ist vieles viel
aber ich möchte wenigstens die wahrheit
kennen doch auch der für adoptionen
zuständigen behörde findet man es laufe
alles gut
[Musik]
wenn uns jemand um sein doch sie bietet
dann finden wir dieses dossier meist in
relativ kurzer zeit etwa innerhalb eines
monats im nächsten monat findet dann in
der regel das erste treffen statt
die wesentlichen hinweise in bezug auf
die adoption die aus rechtlicher sicht
notwendig sind und zum beispiel die
geburtsurkunden der kinder bei den
kindern auf sri lanka waren die dossiers
diesbezüglich komplett die
geburtsurkunden sind da aber sind die
geburtsurkunden echt hören sie es
handelt sich um geburtsurkunden wenn sie
die srilankischen behörden unterzeichnet
und abgestempelt haben gleich bar mit
thailand oder den philippinen heute wir
haben nicht die kapazität diese
dokumente zu verifizieren sie zurück zu
schicken weil es früher einmal einen
betrug gegen hat im fall von sri lanka
ist es weniger die richtigkeit der
geburtsurkunde als die richtigkeit der
abstammung welche angefragt wird wenn
also in einem dossier auf der
geburtsurkunde der name der mutter xy
ist und auf der adoptions urkunde steht
bei der mutter ein anderer name dann
sollte man sich doch schon ein paar
fragen stellen oder nicht absolut diese
fragen muss man stellen
das ist aber nicht geschehen ich kann
dazu nichts sagen ich war nicht dabei
ich kann auf jeden fall nicht bestätigen
dass man sich keine fragen gestellt
hatte stehen die kantone neuenburg um
bei diesem beispiel zu bleiben nicht in
der verantwortung in dieser sache
der kanton hat eine verantwortung die
man jedoch in zusammenhang mit den
ereignissen sehen muss und außerdem
handelt es sich bei der frage nach der
verantwortung um eine rechtliche frage
also müsste man sie der rechtsabteilung
stellen oder besser noch
staatsrat
genau das haben wir getan
wir verlangten ein interview mit der sp
stadträtin monika mehr hefti chefin des
erziehungs und bildung der parlaments
und somit zuständig für diese
angelegenheit
sie hat abgelehnt dann haben wir den
gesamten staatsrat von neuenburg
angefragt wieder eine absage
die regierung schreibt uns die
entscheidungskompetenz für eine adoption
fällt in die zuständigkeit der
justizbehörde und jene der
ausweispapiere in die des bundes eine
erstaunliche antwort
der bundesrat hat nämlich in einer
mitteilung vom 14
februar 2018 festgehalten internationale
adoptionen fallen komplett in die
kompetenz der kantonalen behörden
wir sind im wallis bei geil tournee
geil hat 1980 eine glückliche adoption
erlebt sie kamen durch die vermittlung
der schweizerin alice honecker in die
schweiz
in ihrem fall und das ist selten ist die
geburtsurkunde korrekt so macht sie sich
auf die suche nach ihrer leiblichen
mutter meine eltern haben mir von anfang
an gesagt dass ich adoptiert bin meine
mutter konnte mich nicht behalten
deshalb übergab sie mich an
adoptiveltern die sich sehnlichst ein
kind wünschten eine adoptivmutter hat
das immer sehr positiv geschildert ein
idyllisches bild das brutal zusammen
bricht als geil 2017 erstmals in einem
tv bericht vom kinderhandel und sri
lanka
ich hatte plötzlich den eindruck dass
mein ganzes leben falsch ist das klingt
vielleicht idiotisch weil ich doch eine
solide basis habe mit einer tollen
familie aber plötzlich gibt es keine
logik mir keine rationalität
das geht an die nieren und ich hatte das
gefühl gar nicht mehr zu existieren
geil nimmt kontakt auf zur schweizer
botschaft in colombo
sie will ihre leibliche mutter finden
die botschaft macht die mutter ausfindig
geil trifft sie in colombo sie fallen
sich in die arme
aber geil ist unsicher sie verlangt
einen dna test
die antwort ist brutal es ist nicht ihre
mutter
ich fühlte mich sehr schuldig schuldig
wofür dass sich diese mutter hoffnungen
gemacht habe sie dachte doch auch sie
hätte ihre tochter gefunden und dann bin
ich es gar nicht
ich hatte von anfang an meine zweifel
als ich die dokumente aus sri lanka
studierte jemand von der botschaft sagte
mir noch ach dokumente in sri lanka das
ist nicht dasselbe wie in der schweiz
es ist normal wenn einiges nicht
übereinstimmt aber es ist schon ihre
mutter
wir zeigen geil ein dokument des
bundesamts für ausländerfragen von 1982
es handelt sich um das eintritts
formular in die schweiz für adoptiv
kinder zum zeitpunkt der antragstellung
ist die identität des kindes oft nicht
bekannt oder ungenau
aus diesem grund verwenden wir den namen
der uns angegeben wurde
selbst wenn er nicht ganz exakt ist oder
nicht mit der realität übereinstimmt
diese tatsache ist unwichtig denn die
echte identität des kindes wird bei
seiner ankunft mit hilfe eines gültigen
passes gebildet werden
schockiert sie am meisten dass hier
steht diese tatsache sei unwichtig
einnahme definiert welche personen man
werden wird es ist die essenz eines
menschen
wir sind doch menschen und keine kleinen
welpen wir sind menschen und denen gibt
man einen namen
ich finde das sehr patriarchalisch
bedeutet nach diese armen kleinen kinder
wir werden sie retten
das ist ein kleines detail damit soll
man uns nicht auf die nerven gehen wir
sorgen dafür dass sie ein richtiges
leben haben wir geben ihnen auch einen
namen aber wir sind in sri lanka durch
und hat nicht der storch vor die haustür
unserer adoptiveltern gelegt man kann
nicht einfach die wurzeln abschneiden
und so tun als habe es diesen teil ii
gegeben
macht er entmutigenden erfahrungen mit
der schweizer botschaft in colombo sucht
geilen ihre leibliche mutter auf eigene
faust
ich habe meine mutter zum ersten mal in
einem hotel in sri lanka getroffen
das war eine merkwürdige begegnung denn
sie ist für mich eine unbekannte haben
sie auch hier einen dna test gemacht
der test habe ich letztes jahr gemacht
die resultate habe ich im mai bekommen
nach all den schlechten erfahrungen
wollte ich einfach ganz sicher sein
ist es wirklich meine mutter der test
ist positiv
das resultat hat viel ausgelöst ich
durfte plötzlich einen teil sri lanka in
mir habe ich durfte mich für meine
herkunft interessieren und durfte
wirklich zwei meter haben
[Musik]
geil kam über die vermittlung von alice
honecker in die schweiz
alice honecker hat neben der
vermittlerin dollars silva den handel
mit sri lankischen kindern ermöglicht
die organisation mit sitz in st gallen
hat in den jahren 1980 bis 2000 am
meisten kinder aus sri lanka in die
schweiz gebracht
mehr als 250 adoptionen sind durch sie
zustande gekommen
in sri lanka arbeitete honecker mit
einem anwalt zusammen der den baby
handel in die wege leitete ich habe sie
1995 kennen meine eltern hatten sich das
gewünscht dass ich sie kennen lernen
bevor sie stirbt
für meine eltern war sie die frau die
ihr leben verändert hatte
[Musik]
der kanton st gallen gibt eine
detaillierte studie zu den
vermittlungsaktivitäten von alice
honecker in auftrag von den jahren 1979
bis 1997 als sie starb der bericht sagt
ganz klar dass das einzige interesse
dieser dame finanzieller natur machen es
ist eindeutig
[Musik]
sarah ineichen trifft in st gallen
tamara kramer die ebenfalls auf sri
lanka adoptiert wurde
sie haben einen termin bei der
kantonsregierung und zwar aus gutem
grund beide kamen durch die vermittlung
von alice honecker in die schweiz
tamara und sarah wollen wissen weshalb
die behörden damals die augen
verschlossen
ob schon die unsauberen machenschaften
bei der adoption aus sri lanka der
öffentlichkeit bekannt waren
[Musik]
die frage ist ob der kanton seine
verantwortung von damals anerkennt und
den adoptierten heute hilft
regierungsrat martin klöti ist zuständig
für dieses system bitte kann und auf
bundesebene funktioniert mit entries
prozent wo stimmen relativ schnell
der bericht von st gallen zeigt dass
alice honecker vom kanton eine
arbeitserlaubnis erhalten hatte obschon
sie die rechtlichen bedingungen nicht
erfüllt
und dieses jahr für jahr während 25
jahren mit einem kleinen unterbruch von
einigen monaten
der bericht betont
der kanton st gallen hat seine
kontrollpflicht bei der
vermittlungstätigkeit von alice honecker
nicht genügend ernst genommen
[Musik]
tschuldigung erwartet steht der kanton
st galler heute in der verantwortung die
jury
natürlich hat der staat die
verantwortung wer sonst nur wir können
niemanden mehr zur verantwortung ziehen
und deswegen ist die art der anerkennung
der verantwortung eine andere
sie muss generell sein mit einer form
von entschuldigung dass dinge in jener
zeit geschehen sind die heute nie mehr
geschehen würden
die von alice honecker gegründete
stiftung organisiert schon lange keine
adoption mehr
doch sie hat etwa 250 dossiers aus jener
zeit archiviert und weigert sich diese
an den kanton auszuhändigen
dieses archiv das größte zu den
produktionen aus sri lanka
das gehört doch in professionelle hände
wir haben ein staatsarchiv wo eben
solche akten geordnet werden nur dazu
müsste ich erst einmal zu diesen akten
kommen und wir haben sie nicht erhalten
und ich bin mit ihnen wir müssen hier
etwas investieren sinne von einer
professionellen archivierung
da es sich um eine private stiftung
handelt hat der kanton aber nicht das
recht die herausgabe der dossiers zu
verlangen und der bund argumentiert es
sei nicht seine aufgabe einzugreifen
das archiv wird nicht professionell
geführt wer garantiert uns dass diese
dossiers nicht einfach verschwinden
das kann niemand garantieren wir sind
zuständig für die aktuellen vermitteln
sie sprechen eine private organisation
an die damals legal funktionierte und
die dem gesetz des kantons unterliegt
wir wissen dass der kanton st gallen mit
dieser stiftung diesbezüglich in kontakt
ist aber mir nicht kurzum bund und
kanton schieben sich gegenseitig den
schwarzen peter zu doch die zeit drängt
sarah ineichen hatte ihr dossier von der
stiftung honecker verlangt erhalten hat
sie die dokumente einer anderen
adoptierten was zeigt wie fehlerhaft
dieses archiv geführt wird
sarah will den heutigen verantwortlichen
der stiftung einen besuch abstatten und
ihm die falschen dokumente zurück
bringen
[Applaus]
wir begleiten sie
vielleicht würden vielleicht sieht es
ist schön dass sie wie sie geschickt
das sehe ich eine der name vom innere
leiblichen mutter geworden
doch nun formiert und signieren von der
adoption lothar späth eigentlich gern
mit ines gesprächsmöglichkeit gästen
dass sie alle dossiers würde die
staatsarchiv übergang und die freunde
schon mal seit ich den posten sind nur
die informationen zutaten die felder und
landepunkt das und da hat mir habe mir
die dame zeit vom kanton bern haben
einen kräftigen schub das heißt ich
musste jetzt der frauenbewegung zu
beraten und wenn alle adoptiv härtere
sorgte habe den wert sie bereit der die
unterlagen da hilft es auch im
voranschlag betroffenen nasa archiv das
thema gemacht wieso weshalb es darum
dass die adoptierte jetzt gern ihres
erachtete die dosis ohne irgendeine
chance ihre älteren kinder wird mit kind
und nichts wie man heißt wo hat dass man
hunde älteren überhaupt ist freiwillig
gerne weitere treffen denn er hatte
geburtstag
stolpe und hec wacker und cavani sahen
über trauer alles honecker hier und das
ist nicht richtig
der andere lieber dosierte
verhütungspille verlassen wissen das
sind zum beispiel stellichte ruf taucht
vor babys stellige erstellt vor ihrer
mutter wo stark familie xy hätte gerne
herzlich bitten ins dunkel
man hätte gerne sleeps sind um hätte da
es gern mit dunklen haaren laura
konsolidiert aber dass man ständig
machen zu können
ich habe mich unwohl gefühlt schon an
diesem ort zu sein
ihm gegenüber als adoptierte person vor
ihm zu stehen und andererseits auch
trotzdem unsere rechte einzufordern
weil es gibt viele adoptierte die
schwierigkeiten haben für ihre rechte
einzustehen weil es ihnen heute
psychologisch einfach nicht gut geht
sarah ist auf dem weg zu pedro sutter er
ist sozialarbeiter und hat früher im
bereich adoptionen gearbeitet
[Musik]
pedro suter hätte er 1984 die nachfolge
von alice honecker antreten sollen
noch bevor er die leitung der stiftung
übernimmt will er sich in sri lanka ein
eigenes bild von den lokalen bedingungen
der adoption machen was er da entdeckt
schockiert ihn zutiefst
in der folge kündigt petra suthe
detailliert wurde baby fahren swiss
ausgesät wie ich dass sie für die ich
hätte die art von adoption kann ich
nicht unterstützen
also das ist ganz einfach ruft sie wo
sechs frauen auf matratzen kläger sind
mit der frisch geborenen babys und sind
wahrscheinlich zwei drei wochen zog sie
bis zur übergabe verkriecht pedro suter
schreibt damals einen vernichtenden
bericht heute noch erinnert sich petra
suter das addison egger ihn damals in
sri lanka etwas merkwürdiges anvertraut
hatte
ich glaube am 31 august 84 km sie in
colombo an und noch am gleichen tag habe
ich sie getroffen dort bei frau cavani
sein und dann hat sie mir gesagt sie sei
kürzlich mit herrn doktor oder auf dem
bundesamt gewesen und habe dort mit dem
obersten chef gesprochen und es werde
nun eine schweizerisch einheitliches
verfahren erlassen
das heißt in zukunft sei die personalien
durch gabe der kinder wieder mit lx
erlaubt das war irgendein problem dass
das nicht mehr möglich war
per telex und dann war das komplizierter
für die aktive eltern und sie hat ja
wieder denn quasi den weg frei gemacht
zusammen mit herrn oehler also das ziel
war eine erleichterung der prozedur
ja das war so nach dieser aussage ganz
klar
edgar oehler der mit addison egger beim
bundesamt für ausländerfragen vorstellig
wird ist kein unbekannter
[Musik]
edgar oehler gilt als könig von st
gallen gefürchtet und respektiert
cvp nationalrat zwischen 1971 und 1995
enger freund von bundesrat kurt furgler
damaliger chef des justiz und
polizeidepartements
größter arbeitgeber im kanton st gallen
mächtiger lobbyist für die
zigarettenindustrie
gemäss der zeitschrift bilanz beläuft
sich sein vermögen auf 175 millionen
franken
zwischen 1980 und 1984 adoptiert edgar
oehler vier mädchen aus sri lanka durch
die vermittlungsagentur von alice
honecker er ist also direkt betroffen
deshalb stellt sich die frage was haben
edgar oehler und alice honecker vom
bundesamt für ausländerfragen verlangt
in bezug auf sri lanka
[Musik]
gemäss pedro sutter wollte er den
adoptionsprozess beschleunigen
dann erinnerte ich wichtig wer das sieht
ja 18 jahre und seither ist viel zu
kleine wohnung gegangen
also gilt in dieser sache aber vom leben
das geschäft hat frau monika von ihrem
schutz profitieren
ich habe sie sehr wenig getroffen
34 mal
aber das hätte sie ich halte es nicht
mehr gemerkt dass ich sie unterstützen
monika ton wagte es wohl nicht etwas
gegen frau honecker zu unternehmen weil
sie sie geschützt habe
viele medien berichteten über den
kinderhandel in sri lanka erinnern sie
sich daran gar keine erinnerung
sie waren journalist chefredaktor
sie saßen in kommissionen in denen es um
außenpolitik gehen diese frage betrifft
sie auch persönlich wie ist es möglich
dass sie davon noch nie gehört haben
mehr als den hinweis auf detailfragen
und verlorene erinnerungen ist nicht zu
erfahren
sarah trifft sich mit die dagong die
sich ebenfalls für die rechte der
adoptierten einsetzt die da ist
präsidentin von born in lebanon der
vereinigung für adoptierte aus dem
libanon sarah präsidiert back to the
roots die organisation für adoptierte
aus sri lanka
schön dass wir die arbeit zwischen
unseren vereinigungen etwas vorantreiben
können
mal schauen welche anliegen wir
gemeinsam haben zb auf bundesebene
worauf legt die momentan den fokus seit
einem jahr haben 172 adoptierte aus sri
lanka in der schweiz mit uns kontakt
aufgenommen etwa jeden dritten tag kommt
eine neue person dazu bei uns haben
viele schon an andere türen angeklopft
aber am schluss landen alle bei uns wir
tun was wir können aber es übersteigt
langsam unsere kapazität sri lanka ist
wohl nur die spitze des eisbergs in der
geschichte der internationalen adoption
in den jahren zwischen 1980 und 2000
wurde nun 13.400 ausländischer kinder in
die schweiz adoptiert internationale
adoptionen boom in der schweiz und in
anderen westlichen ländern sind sie die
lösung für ungewollt kinderlose paare
in ländern wie korea indien brasilien
chile guatemala meist durch bewaffnete
konflikte der stabilisiert sind die
adoptions praktiken genauso fragwürdig
wie in sri lanka
[Musik]
wir wollen das beispiel libanon genauer
anschauen
in der 1980 er jahren wütet im libanon
ein brutaler bürgerkrieg das land
versinkt im chaos
internationale adoptionen haben
hochsaison
die dagegen kommt 1984 in beirut zu welt
wir treffen sie am hafen von juni im
norden von beirut
ich bin nie mehr hierher zurückgekehrt
genau von hier habe ich damals den
libanesischen boden verlassen
mein erster transport fand in einem
dieser kleinen fischerbootes stadt die
mich und meine adoptiveltern zur fähre
auf zypern brachte von wo aus die reise
dann weiter ging es gibt wenige menschen
geht das risiko auf sich nahmen hierher
zu kommen
zum beispiel meine adoptiveltern die
keine angst haben als war sie damals ich
war acht tage an
acht tage und die sache ist erledigt
denn das im libanon angewendete system
ist noch etwas perfider als jenes in sri
lanka dank einer falschen geburtsurkunde
eines arztes wurde dieser als
biologische tochter ihrer adoptiveltern
erfasst offiziell wurde sie also nie
adoptiert eine radikale methode die
damals in mehreren ländern praktiziert
wurde
um die kontrollen der behörden zu
umgehen
zurück in der schweiz haben die
adoptiveltern die da noch formell
adoptiert doch längst nicht alle
adoptiveltern haben das getan
im libanon profitieren damals auf dem
adoptionsmarkt alle arten von vermittler
von den kriegswirren anwälte ärzte
schwestern hebammen
über verschiedene unterschiedliche
quellen stoßen wir auf eine tonaufnahme
die ohne das wissen der vermittlerin vor
einigen jahren aufgezeichnet wurde die
person beschreibt wie es damals vor sich
ging
alle ärzte sind keine kollegen
sie wissen alle dass ich die adoptionen
mache sie haben vertrauen in mich auch
wenn es um die ausgaben geht geld das
man dem krankenhaus zahlen muss oder dem
arzt
einmal habe ich einem arzt gesagt wie
viel wollen sie er hat gesagt 240.000
dollar
sie wollen einfach das geld sie nehmen
nicht einmal einen scheck man muss das
waisenhaus bezahlen die dokumente und
mein honorar ich kassiere das geld ein
5000 dollar pro adoption davon bekomme
ich dann nicht einmal 1500 dollar
in bern im bundesarchiv finden wir die
bestätigung für diese vorgehensweisen
der acht mann recherche journalist bei
rts durfte den diplomatischen
briefverkehr der schweizer botschaft dem
libanon anschauen jedoch ohne zu filmen
gemäss den unterlagen macht das
bundesamt für ausländerfragen die
schweizer botschaft im libanon auf eine
verdächtige vermittlung aufmerksam
dieser wird von einer anwältin in beirut
betrieben die horen der
vermittlungsgebühren verlangt am 6
august 1987 schreibt das bundesamt für
ausländerfragen ich gebe ihnen die
adresse einer libanesischen anwältin
welche in beirut als vermittlerin bei
adoptionen fungiert sie vermittelt die
kinder und versucht die adoptionspapiere
zu bekommen
außerdem organisiert sie die reise der
adoptiveltern und verlangt dafür einen
pauschalpreis von 26.000 schweizer
franken
im archiv finden wir ein schreiben des
rechtsberaters der schweizer botschaft
dass auf ein auskunftsersuchen über die
rechtlichen voraussetzungen für eine
adoption im libanon antwortet und
schreiben werden verschiedene
vorgehensweisen beschrieben
am fünften jahr war 1988 wird vor den
gepflogenheiten im land gewarnt
[Musik]
um ein normales und gesundes kind zu
bekommen wendet man sich an bestimmte
ärzte und entbindungsklinik
[Musik]
man spricht mit dem arzt der einem im
voraus ein neugeborenes einer mutter zu
spricht die er neugeborenes gleich nach
der geburt weg geben möchte
in den 1980 er jahren spielen im libanon
die christlichen geistlichen eine
zentrale rolle
die religiösen gerichte genehmigten
adoptionen und die christlichen
kinderheime konnten wenn nötig sogar
geburtsurkunden ausstellen
zwei namen tauchen immer wieder auf das
kinderheim und das waisenhaus bompastor
[Musik]
wir haben einen termin in der altstadt
von sidon beim griechisch katholischen
erzbischof der amtierende erzbischof war
damals noch nicht im amt er antwortet im
namen seiner kirche es gab diesen
waisenhäusern menschen und wände immer
wieder kinder weg brachten
das war nicht böswillig sie wollten das
nicht tun
aber der krieg zwingend einen so zu
handeln aber der krieg entschuldigt
nicht alles
die vermittler die aus der adoption an
geschäft machten hatten gute adressen
das bestätigt eine notiz der schweizer
botschaft in beirut vom 22 dezember 1980
darin sind die empfehlungen der
verantwortlichen schwester des weißen
hauses of the pool festgehalten
sie erklärt dass das waisenhaus das
prozedere abkürzen kann um die dinge zu
beschleunigen
die lange wartezeit kann verkürzt werden
wenn die adoptiveltern selbst ein kind
finden zum beispiel durch die
vermittlung eines krankenhauses oder
eines arztes auch in diesen fällen ist
das waisenhaus servern bereit die
erforderlichen formalitäten zu erledigen
anders gesagt sei versace pohl und lever
pasta haben bei diesem handel zumindest
eine unterstützende rolle gespielt
der protestantische pfarrer hubble hat
das konfessionelle gericht präsidiert
welches während des bürgerkrieges über
die adoptionen befand mussten nur woher
diese babys kam das war die große frage
für uns für mich ganz besonders
und es ist auch einer der gründe weshalb
wir die adoptionen nach einiger zeit
nicht mehr durchgeführt haben weil es
nicht möglich war zu erfahren wie ihr
die leibliche mutter ist
das war für mich als präsident des
gerichts ein dilemma soll ich diese
frage stellen welche frage die frage wer
die mutter ist wer die eltern sind wieso
sie das kind weggegeben haben und so
weiter
bevor ich für eine attraktion
entscheider soll ich diese frage stellen
oder nicht denn vielleicht stellt sie ja
das kind eines tages aber vielleicht
auch nicht
und wie haben sie für sich diese frage
beantwortet
[Musik]
ich habe entschieden es nicht wissen zu
wollen
ich habe beschlossen dass es eine
entscheidung zwischen zwei schlechten
varianten ist es ist schlechtes zu
wissen und schlecht es nicht zu heißen
damals dachte ich es sei weniger
schlecht es nicht zu wissen
für die der aber war es unabdingbar es
zu wissen
ich war wie besessen davon
herauszufinden wer meine leibliche
mutter ist
ohne antworten ist man zu allem bereit
ich war bereit im libanon zu leben ich
war bereit zu sterben
mein einziges ziel im leben war meine
leiblichen eltern zu finden
aber eigentlich suchte ich nicht meine
eltern sondern die wahrheit damit ich in
meinem leben weiterkommen
und genau das ist das problem betrachtet
man die adoptions bedingungen aus jener
zeit mit falschen geburtsurkunden ohne
namen der leiblichen mutter wird die
suche nach der wahrheit praktisch
unmöglich
es wird zehn jahre dauern bis die da
ihre leibliche mutter findet
sie zieht für einige jahre nach beirut
sie lernt arabisch und schafft es den
namen ihrer mutter und ihre damalige
adresse ausfindig zu machen
[Musik]
hier sind wir vor dem haus in dem eine
leibliche mutter damals wohnte ich habe
dieses haus sehr lange gesucht ich war
mir nicht sicher ob es wirklich hier ist
doch dann traf ich die hausbesitzerin
sie saß dort auf der bank schaute mich
ganz intensiv an und um momente auf
arabisch ich weiß wer du bist
da habe ich begriffen dass ich am
richtigen ort bin denn ich gleichem
einer leiblichen mutter sehr 2012 wird
sie von einem libanesischen fernsehteam
kontaktiert sie wollen eine reportage
über die das suche machen und bieten
ihre hilfe an
sie schaffen es die mutter aufzuspüren
und entdeckten etwas unglaubliches
sie lebt seit 27 jahren in der schweiz
eine zug stunde vom dorf entfernt in dem
die da aufgewachsen ist in beirut traut
die da ihren ohren nicht
darf ich dich fragen wieso du deine mama
so ist ich möchte sie kennenlernen
ich möchte wissen wie sie aussieht ich
möchte wissen wie ihr leben verlaufen
ist
in meinem leben ist viel passiert
ich habe mich so nach dir gesehen aber
gleichzeitig hätte ich solche angst ich
habe nur geweint ich war sehr krank ich
ging von einem psychiater zum nächsten
ich wollte meinem leben ein ende setzen
es ist so schwer am telefon darüber zu
reden
kein problem um ganz sicher zu sein
macht die da einen dna-test er ist
positiv
also macht sie sich zusammen mit dem
libanesischen fernsehen auf den weg in
die schweiz
[Musik]
ist ihr gut ja und dir
ich muss dich die ganze zeit anschauen
ich hab dich weg gegeben aber nie ganz
ich habe immer gehofft ich eines tages
wieder
[Musik]
wenn man seine wurzeln sucht dann
bedeutet das nicht nur den namen der
familie herauszufinden
es bedeutet auch eine geschichte zu
hören eine schöne wurde eine
schmerzhafte und meistens ist es eine
schmerzhafte ich bin gespalten
einerseits muss sich gewisse dinge
respektieren die einfach zu schmerzhaft
sind und andererseits ist er auch mein
bedürfnis licht ins dunkel zu bringen
damit ich überhaupt weitermachen kann
die geschichte von wieder die im libanon
begonnen hat ist außergewöhnlich aber
sie ist nicht allein mit ihrem schicksal
tausenden von adoptierten wie die da
wurde immer wieder erklärt dass sie
durch die adoption vor einem schlimmeren
leben bewahrt worden sein
für mich machen solche aussagen
überhaupt keinen sinn
sie sprechen von rettung aber die
wahrheit ist dass da eine mutter war die
in kriegszeiten schwanger wurde von
einem mann mit dem sie nicht verheiratet
war und der er gewalt angetan hatte
diese frau muss tierbaby ganz alleine
zur welt bringen
in einem land in dem die frauenrechte
nicht respektiert werden
und indem sie das kind nicht offiziell
anmelden konnte man sagte ihr sei besser
sich vom kind zu trennen
das ist die grundlage auf denen
internationale adoptionen möglich
gemacht wurden
es ging also ganz klar nicht darum eine
frau in einer schwierigen situation zu
helfen und auch nicht einem kind das
vielleicht seine eltern im krieg
verloren hätte und auch nicht eine armen
frau zu helfen meine mutter war nicht
arm
diese aussagen über rettung diene nur
als vorwand um die nachfrage nach
adoptions kindern aus der westlichen
welt zu verdecken
[Musik]
lehmann
als die da ihre mutter wieder fand hat
sie etwas grundlegendes erfahren
ich habe begriffen dass meine mutter in
einer psychisch enorm verletzlichen
situation war als sie alleine den
entscheid rapses von mir zu trennen
es ging nicht darum dass sie als mutter
ihr kind nicht wollte
[Musik]
diese erkenntnis hat etwa 70 meine
wunden geheilt
[Musik]
die wunden heilen oder sie zumindest
erträglicher machen
[Musik]
das so
das himmel
[Musik]
mal hier
trier
[Musik]